[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
merci bernard
[Musique]
et
bonsoir je vous parle de la rue des
entrepreneurs je suis actuellement avec
un jeune et sympathique chef
d'entreprise qui est de ceux qui croient
que l'invention est la clé de la reprise
économique
jean firma de la rue vous venez d'ouvrir
cette magnifique laverie de cerveau à
neuilly pourriez vous nous expliquer
pourquoi
oui bien sûr c'est simple si vous voulez
les souvenirs pèse terriblement lourd
nous possédons tous en nous des
souvenirs qui nous hante qui nous
paralyse
j'ai pensé qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose et j'ai décidé d'ouvrir le précise
le succès a été immédiat
oui bien sûr on n'avait pas idée du
nombre de gens qui nous supplient tous
les jours pour qu'on ait des barrages
avant mauvais souvenir la scène ils sont
légions vraiment vraiment maintenant si
vous voulez bien entrer merci
[Musique]
la laverie de cerveau de monsieur
delarue est ouverte depuis le 3 mai 1982
monsieur vous avez aussi des mauvais
souvenirs oubliés
oui quand j'ai pissé dans ma culotte à
l'école en 8e 1 jacques decour
mademoiselle am trying to as tu cherches
à oublier la première fois que chez
manger un cassoulet parce que s'il est
vous mademoiselle la première fois la
première fois qua première fois qu'un
type ma peau cdma bien pousser des eaux
le salon mais sur toute la ligne
et évidemment vous cherchez à l'oublier
la wii sercel oubliée voilà
mais tout le monde a des mauvais
souvenirs ainsi vous je suis certain
qu'elles ont - qui vous obsède non au
oui hein ah vous voyez lequel je ne vous
en parle et non non non mes côtés pour
vous prouver l'efficacité de la méthode
nous allons vous en débarrasser tout de
suite sylvia l'écrire sur cette feuille
au nom milieu des nitrates c'est
complètement confidentielle
vous pensez bien ça ne regarde même
nature que vous n'allez pas mettre dans
une màj nous ne sommes pas des sauvages
on a là dieu merci il existe d'autres
techniques
n'ayez crainte la halle et prenez place
sur cette chaise
alors voilà je vous explique sylviane va
vous souffler dans l'oreille droite et
votre mauvais souvenirs sortir ensemble
à gauche si liam
et voilà terminé fini à $ vous souvenez
quelque chose on ne rien et bien
maintenant c'est vous permettez je vais
vous lire votre mauvais souvenirs et
nous en rions enfants voilà j'ai écrasé
trois enfants un soir où j'étais ivre
sur une petite route du calvados
sensationnel les chiens ont un sens
prodigieux de l'orientation
monsieur tino de rossi avait le 10
juillet 1926 était perdre son chien
napoléon à une distance de plus de trois
mille six cent cinquante kilomètres de
son domicile
quarante ans et trois jours plus tard en
tentant d'en gratter à sa porte il eu la
surprise d'y trouver un chien
c'était presque le même pari les
japonais n'ont qu'un testicule
c'est facile à vérifier il suffit
d'aller à l'ambassade du japon et de
prier l'ambassadeur de vous le montrer
stockholm à l'usagé des personnes
sujettes au mal des ascenseurs un
ingénieur de new york a mis au point un
ascenseur fixe c'est l'immeuble qui
monte et qui descend autour de la cabine
chicago le professeur john bell fils du
centre de recherche génétique lincoln
déclare c'est par suite de leur
adaptation fonctionnel à la vie dans un
milieu totalement dépourvu de lumière
que les suppositoires sont généralement
aveugle bonjour une fois de plus un
homme et une femme ont été victimes
d'une publicité abusive et mensongère
d'une agence de voyage aventure
aujourd'hui ils osent parler comment
tout cela at il commencé monsieur
merlande au retour a fait simplement un
jour nous avons reçu une documentation
très alléchante de l'agent ce voyage
aventure et nous avons été séduits oui
ça je dois dire tout de suite
qu'est-ce que vous promettait aux
plusieurs formules intéressantes
moi j'avais un faible pour la traversée
de la forêt amazonienne à vélo avec
baignade piranha et lutte avec des
réducteurs de têtes mais ma femme
préférée la formule sécheresse et danger
c'est à dire le sahara est ouest avec
tempête de sable panne de voiture et
pillards oui mais je sais pas laisser
d'américaines donne pas le frisson oui
c'est ça alors nous avons opté pour la
formule désert avait 1200 francs pour 15
jours et de personnes 9
ils feront avec le supplément maladie le
supplément maladie oui ça n'était pas
une mauvaise idée
en plus des garanties peur blessure
insolation soif et cetera il proposait
un supplément maladie qui permettait un
petit détour dans les zones infestées
par la malaria ou la fièvre jaune pour
il s'offre en plus sur le connais c'est
que ça ne valait pas la peine de s'en
priver
donc 9000 francs ce qui est tout de même
une somme
quand avez vous senti la supercherie
pour la première fois hors tout de suite
dès notre arrivée dans le petit plein de
tardif
oui vous avez dû deux premières nuits
dans un gourbi avec l'habitant et ses
chefs en fait gourbi on s'y retrouvait
dans une chambre avec deux doubles
rideaux salle de bain et tenez vous bien
au chaud baignoire et pris ses cheveux
après 5 heures d'avion je dois dire que
ça ne m'est pas de bonne humeur
c'est incroyable alors le lendemain on
part avec la jeep roule roule
un jour deux jours trois jours
parlons du montant des biens pas l'ombre
d'une panne
roger était dans un tel état
d'énervement qu'au quatrième jour je lui
ai dit écoute crève une durite toi même
sinon s'en sortira pas et vous l'avez
fait j'étais bien obligé sinon on
risquait de dépasser la zone de tempête
de sable 4 parenthèse on n'a jamais vu
un pas là que dunn c'est comme les
scorpions pas un seul pendant le séjour
à tout ça je m'en souviendrai vous
rendez compte l'organisation
on les a rencontrés le 11e jour alors
que par contrat le dio être attaqué en
fin de première semaine nous vous savez
quand on a 15 jours de vacances c'est
vraiment déprimant alors c'est ma femme
qui les a vu la première devenir une
dune je les avais une trentaine une
tribu du sud les léo chiny
très dangereux bonjour donne le nom oui
moi j'étais verbe de terol oui enfin les
vraies vacances commencé ta mais elle
commençait alors pour qu'ils nous
pillent sans violenter
je décide de nous enterrer comme sa
tactique lawrence d'arabie
comme chef
on avait du sable dans les yeux dans la
bouche j'étais à moitié mort c'était
formidable
eh bien vous n'allez pas me croire
on nettoie pas enterré depuis cinq
minutes qu'ils ont foncé sur nous ils
nous ont été ré ils nous ont dit pas
peur pas peur vous serez vous changé et
nous sommes offert du thé je n'invente
rien il y en a même qui m'a fait un
baise main pour quand même pas se [ __ ]
du monde et le supplément maladie
foutaise on est revenu avec deux kilos
de plus chacun heureusement ma femme
s'est cassé la jambe ou retour à howick
sido nous aurions eu l'air de quoi
témoignages accablants qui aidera je
l'espère nos amis à regarder la
publicité à deux fois avant de la croire
monsieur et madame et relandeau une
dernière question pour vos vacances
l'année prochaine toujours l'aventuré
bien sûr sinon c'est pas des vacances
nous avons une documentation d'une
agence qui allaient très sérieuse c'est
à dire on prend l'avion à roissy
le lundi matin à 8h 5h après
c'est-à-dire midi heure locale on vous
fait sauter sur le front irano irakien
ça a l'air pas mal foch vous n'avez pas
peur de vous faire berner une seconde
fois sa barre peut jamais être certain
de rien mais il met une clause qui nous
a beaucoup rassuré laquelle si on en
revient on est remboursé
si vous avez quelques problèmes séduire
la jeune femme dont vous désirez
ardemment posséder le corps et l'esprit
je vous conseille de lui faire croire
que vous avez un beau frère
ashotyan au projet bonjour bonjour vous
êtes dit que j'avais un beau frère vous
avez un beau frère roger bourget roger
soyez mieux maintenant projet bien sûr
il ya un truc
explications bien sûr je n'ai pas de
beaux frères simplement me promenant
tout à l'heure dans la forêt j'ai
rencontré cet homme et à son air veut le
chafouin j'ai compris qu'il était sinon
de gauche en tout cas très pauvre et je
les soudoyer tout simplement et contre
un bien pauvre billets de 500 francs
il a bien voulu jouer le rôle du beau
frère je suis de mèche
si la méthode dite du beau frère n'a pas
fonctionné je vous conseille vivement de
faire croire la femme de votre vie que
vous avez bien connu fernand sardou
josiane projet vous savez que c'est bien
connu faire danseurs 2g c'est
merveilleux soit mien soit mia bien sûr
il ya un truc
explications bien sûr je ne connais pas
fernand sardou
mais je ne risque pas d'être prise au
dépourvu
[Musique]
non
jours
[Musique]
attention aux enchères
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
je changerais bien ce bouddha contre un
autre boudin si possible moins vulgaire
échangerait volontiers ce minable contre
un autre minable mais ouattara bout d'un
minable bout d'un minable bout d'un sac
à merde battle points par décision
ministérielle en date d'aujourd'hui même
tous les gros mots seront désormais
interdits à l'antenne souffle connard
sacamerd couilles molles qu d'oignon est
trop qui pète
acapulco le docteur ramirez ramirez chef
du laboratoire reproduction à l'institut
sainte choisi sancho après trois ans de
travaux vient de déclarer les seules
créatures qui s'accouplent en se faisant
face sont l'homme et le sandwich au pâté
philippines
on a découvert au fond de la jungle
impénétrable d'un îlot du pacifique
un soldat japonais qui ignorait que la
guerre de cent ans était finie même
qu'elle avait commencé qui d'ailleurs
s'en foutait complètement italie giorgio
tomasino ministre du tourisme italien
nous rappelle quand la tour de pise
penche vers la droite sait qu'il va
pleuvoir
quand elle penche vers la gauche c'est
que vous arrivez par l'autre bout de la
rue littérature grand poète français
verlaine et est pédéraste mais sa femme
ne savait pas et elle il y aura toujours
qu'elle était un homme
[Musique]
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah bon ac où
placez-vous essence a plus de maison
depuis que oui oui parce que j'étais
carrément déconner oui c'est du bien oui
bakou
pourrait bien encore merci
[Musique]
non ça passe
oooh
[Musique]
abou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
monsieur paulin andré le temps imparti
pour vos dernières volontés est terminée
soyez courageux mon fils c'était fini
les petits vous dansez vous pu danser
que vous y gouzy maintenant c'est qu'on
sonne t console r quand sonne v console
z mais vous ne prenez pas de voyage bah
non je vais le tenter comme sa console n
consonnes elle consonnes et constamment
s et c
c'est pas facile
[Musique]
sur ego là le temps est écoulé à ces
camps à à la maison je trouve tout le
temps pour faire les amis il pleut
dehors
est ce pour cela que nous allons faire
grise mine nous suicider ou nous laisser
aller à regarder la télévision
non bien sûr nous allons réagir et
tenter de nous amuser de façon utile
tout en restant à la maison
tout le monde a chez soi abandonnée dans
un coin du grenier dans la cave ou sur
les genoux de grand-père un aquarium qui
ne sert plus et bien puisque le bon dieu
a voulu faire du mauvais temps pour
punir tous ceux qui ont voté à gauche
nous allons en profiter pour redonner
vie à ce merveilleux objets délaissés
alors de quoi roubaix soin du bien tout
d'abord bien sûr d'un brin d'imagination
puis d'une grosse bouteille d'huile que
vous aurez volé dans la cuisine pendant
que maman est dans sa chambre avec l'ami
de papa vous la verser dans l'aquarium
tout d'un coup
[Musique]
ensuite vous prenez un ouvre-boîte et
vous laisser tomber le contenu d'une
belle boîte de sardines une 2 e et 3
dans le récipient
vous voyez grâce à l'huile l'animal
n'est pas dépaysé il est souriant et
confiant
vous pouvez si vous en possédez rajouter
quelques miettes de thon et voilà le
tour est joué
votre vieille aquarium poussiéreux et
rouillée est redevenu un brillant
bibelots d'intérieur de vos amis auront
plaisir à regarder sur la cheminée et
que vous pourrez même le repasser
pendant l'apéritif au revoir les amis à
la semaine prochaine pourquoi
[Musique]
voyelles eux voyaient eux voyagent à
voyelles eux mais vous ne prenez pas de
consomme au banon tout à l'heure je me
suis fait baiser voyelles
[Musique]